[Music]
so anyway opster
um by the way this guy who's
whoever sent this question and has the
best pfp i've seen
in forever
oh yeah
it's just so silly all right so
it's pixelated because i guess the
internet service at his beach house
isn't great uh he's talking about jim
norton now what he's doing is he's
trying to do what all these youtube
channels do which is he's t he's
clipping the stuff himself he's taking a
clip from a saucy part of the video and
then putting it at the beginning to
catch the attention got to get that opi
anthony algorithm right
for 3 000 views
and then somewhere along the way he
decided he was going to try to take over
the entire [ __ ] show
he even bleeped out [ __ ]
uh
rub your nose if the only reason you
kept norton on board was for the fan
base and not talent we'll end with this
okay look i know you might have thought
this was good and everything what you're
about to say
but
you i wouldn't have uploaded it if the
video quality was this bad right
we'll end with this
jimmy stayed on board
because he was very very talented and i
say was
i don't think he's talented anymore i
really don't
i think jimmy wouldn't not be talented
anymore that's not how that works
you can like not be like if you can set
it up yeah i could say i don't think
he's funny anymore yeah but you can't
say he's not talented because he was
funny and he hasn't like he hasn't lost
that ability he's just
you know i don't know that's he was
great in his element when he was sniping
in and out and then somewhere along the
way he decided he was going to try to
take over the entire [ __ ] show then
why did you do a show with him yeah
why'd you make him partner you did it
and that's exactly what he did and then
he got obsessed with his dumb voices and
he had to squeeze that into everything
we did that i have to i agree with that
i have to agree we agree i actually do
agree with him very much so
yeah not only that he's doing cameos for
his voices and don't get me wrong doing
voices is funny sometimes we do it
sometimes on the show but he is right
when you look back it's every segment
would be chip chipperson would be in it
or uncle paul or it was getting carried
away no it was it was really good and i
actually did like the early chip me too
when it was just like a small bit he did
once in a while he just was like yeah
like [ __ ] and he would just yeah kill
a joke and everybody'd be like and it
was funny because you'd have real heavy
hitter comics in a room and you'd hear
them all go
ah [ __ ] i hate [ __ ] like yeah the
only one who loved him was colin yeah
quinn loved the chip he did
and uh i don't think it was good for the
uh the opening anthony brand in general
but the reason he stayed around so long
was because he was very very talented
100 percent
the list of people and i would love to
name the man why does he always do
[ __ ] haters like this into what he's
saying
bro
how come you're spending the summer at
your beach house and i never see you
with your family
he's spending it vlogging but he's never
with his family like but i have
relationships you have money in a beach
house in a regular house wouldn't you
like spend time with your family in the
summer like that's the whole point of
getting uh two houses and one of them
being a beach located one it's that you
go to the summer yeah you yeah you got
the kids outside running around you know
they're trucking sand all over the house
you're supposed to have a nice little
barbecue he's never doing any of that
true and and before people say
oh uh well you know what family is
privacy or whatever okay but i
understand not posting your kids and
stuff in the videos or even the
instagram but how come there's never any
pictures of stuff
that you'd be doing with your family
that doesn't require opsec right right
how come he's there's never an opie
picture on instagram of like meat
cooking on a barbecue right right or
like a pool in the background of the
barbecue but there's nobody in it so
it's not pictures you know what i mean
it's like oh obviously you're but
obviously you're making enough food that
there's a gathering and the kids will be
there he's never he just sits around
goes ah auntie [ __ ] haters exactly
these people so i can't do it to them
today
but he knows how many times management
was trying to get rid of him
and not only did i i got to say it for
anthony as well we stuck up for jimmy
and kept them uh kept them around he
knows it
big names
huge names
did not want him part of the opium
anthony show
and that is a fact
so uh no he he's he's stuck around
because he was he was very very talented
and he did some great great stuff for
the uh
the opiate anthony show it wasn't
because of his fan base we gave him his
fan base
i hope he knows that
he was just uh nobody from uh from
jersey that had a couple little credits
here and there yeah but you were nobody
too that that that you needed them yeah
i mean
honestly look i'm not i'm not gonna sit
here and pretend and pretend like i'm
not gonna sit here and pretend like
like you know jimmy's a good person or
anything but
that show at its best was when all three
of them were there and that's great i
look
i'm not gonna suck any one of these
three [ __ ] dicks i'm not especially
jimmy or aunt but
you're gonna pretend that jimmy did not
round out a show that otherwise would
have been
you two try like you do remember op when
you guys were on naw you guys were all
wacky had your little wacky bits you
guys were still like goofy wacky guys
you were pretty corny
jimmy gave you guys an edge that you
didn't have before jimmy came along well
you know what else jimmy brought
comics comics jimmy brought comics and
you had boss you wouldn't have patrice
you wouldn't had louie you wouldn't have
burr you wouldn't had any of those
people coming in jim jeffries ricky
gervais colin quinn like there's people
there that again
i'm not
god i hate that opie's so eatable that
he makes you start defending people that
suck the golden age op was when all
these comics would come in yeah and they
all were just [ __ ] hanging out the
night before and they're all still on a
roll and then they all just click right
into ripping on each other while you sat
there and shut up those were the best
episodes yeah the episodes where you
shut up and then burr and louis c.k
would sit there and just rip each
other's souls out for no reason
and then every once in a while you
derail everything and go hey let's go to
[ __ ] lady trucker
i mean [ __ ]
hey what's cigars and scotch saying uh
she's doing that tiki bar show with
those [ __ ] retards
[Laughter]
and then he was smart with our fan base
and he figured out how to get them all
on board on his stuff and good for him
man they were his fan base they were
also his fan base
could you imagine
this is this is just
the arrogance the sheer arrogance of him
that would be like me or you bitching
that frozen has grown to having like his
own following of people that love him
from this community like i'd be like
yeah if somebody went don't you feel
like he's like siphoning your fans i'd
be like no i feel like he's being like a
likable dude on mike which is what he
was asked to do and he's winning people
over which is part of his job was to win
everybody over and he's part of the
thing if if i win some people over and
they go you know what man i wasn't a
merch fan but now i'm starting to become
a merch fan i won you over right doesn't
matter what platform i was on when you
decided you liked me i won you over if
you liked royce hill when you were i i
didn't you know yeah
but but it's but that's supposed to be
likeable no no not you everybody hates
you oh okay yeah there's facts we're
changing up the form there's factions
even in the patreon there's factions of
people that are like i actually like
when virtue's on he's pretty funny and
there's other people like only frozen
should be allowed and it's it's a weird
like this war going on i think it's
pretty funny because both of them are
such good friends and you guys are like
trying to pick sides
um well it's like people and people try
to get do the same thing with us though
yeah
well personally i'm team frozen too oh
she didn't [ __ ] i wish he was still
here so i could be watching his [ __ ]
show instead of being a part of it
man i tell you what dude you're funnier
you're 40 you're the merch man you'd be
a rocket ship if you just want to get
rid of that guy and then like yeah
people always say like what no stop
trying this divide and conquer [ __ ] god
damn it and also what is this
what do we zack attack what are you in
my ear [ __ ] tell me i don't need the
rest of these i don't need screech and
the rest of these losers shut up with
dyed blonde hair the other day in a
dangly earring and he was just like zack
morris from zach attack i was very angry
it really made me mad but then i started
going hey man friends forever wasn't it
implied that he was doing drugs yeah
they never really believed but they
never said it never because it was a
kid's show but it was like he's acting
like a guy on drugs yeah
sex on [ __ ] drugs everyone they do
all the time and it's like you be and
you're and then i always go like okay so
you're just trying to start chickens we
do both have our own show as well
so it's not like one thing is stopping
us from doing the other it's not like
it's yeah it's not like i'm doing night
wave and it's just battering rotc
it's like oh man i just need to cut the
dead weight
look our shows do well but we work well
together i will declare this though
the bad luck boys channel is going to
end up
dominating everything we've ever done i
know i know the real stars are gonna
take over i know